[Musique]
c'est le pire cauchemar de bien des
éleveurs de porcs la peste porcine
africaine
cette maladie qui a décimé des troupeaux
surtout en europe de l'est et en asie
n'a pas encore fait son entrée au canada
mais plusieurs sont d'avis que ce n'est
qu'une question de temps
il ya toutefois une lueur d'espoir sous
la forme d'une course contre la montre
pour développer un vaccin
[Musique]
dans le sud du manitoba loin des villes
et des autoroutes se trouve la petite
communauté huttérite starlight une
trentaine de familles vivent ici de la
production agricole surtout la culture
degré et l'élevage de porcs james au feu
gère les porcheries 15 mai le porcelet
laisse danse est établi chaque année ils
sont engraissés puis vendu un
transformateur
depuis quelques mois il s'inquiète pour
l'avenir de sa ferme et de sa communauté
en voyant ces images d'animaux morts et
les pertes financières des fermiers je
me suis dit ça peut être nous les
prochains axes
[Applaudissements]
l'enjeu c'est la peste porcine africaine
une maladie qui affecte les élevages de
porcs bien connue en afrique où elle est
endémique dans plusieurs pays
la maladie est apparue dans la
république de géorgie en 2007
depuis elle se propage dans les pays du
caucase d'europe de l'est et d'asie
partout sur son passage
elle sème la mort dans les élevages
[Musique]
heureusement cette maladie qui ne
présentent aucun risque pour les humains
n'a pas encore atteint le continent
américain
et c'est la crainte de james au feu
oh j'ai du mal à imaginer comment un
fermier peut faire face à l'euthanasie
de son cheptel et à toutes les
conséquences financières que ça aurait
dont les pertes d'emplois pour nous ce
serait des pertes énormes
contre cette maladie il n'existe aucun
vaccin
mais les choses pourraient bientôt
changer tous les matins le chercheur
d'or grâce kouadio et ses collègues
prennent le traversier pour se rendre à
lille pomme dans l'état de new york
dans ce centre de recherche du
département américain de l'agriculture
laïos dié on étudie loin de la terre
ferme
certains des pathogènes les plus
mortelles pour les animaux togo radio
s'intéresse à la peste porcine africaine
[Musique]
la souche présente en jour j étais très
virulent la quasi totalité des portes
domestique cathay ans mourait il
sangliers sauvages étaient peu à peu
infectées l'épidémie se propageant nous
avons obtenu des fonds pour trouver un
vaccin
la peste porcine africaine est virus
animal parmi les plus complexes de la
planète son génome compte près de 190
gènes dont les fonctions individuelles
sont peu connus les chercheurs de
laâyoune ce biais développe en 2014
un outil informatisé permettant de
prédire le rôle de chacune des protéines
du virus
le but identifier celles qui peuvent
être soustraite génome du virus pour
l'atténuer sans pour autant le détruire
notre choix s'est arrêté sur trois
protéines
la première s'est avérée indispensable
on ne va plus dans lever la deuxième on
pouvait la supprimer mais le virus ne
s'en trouvait pas affecter la troisième
quand tu es une fut la bonne sans elle
le virus devenu inoffensif aux
animations
début 2019 c'est le moment de vérité il
expose des animaux vaccinés au virus
nous avons constaté qu'une faible dose
suffisait pour protéger les ports contre
le virus élevé du vaccin il n'y avait
aucune trace de virulence le vaccin
cause elle même pas de fièvre chez des
animaux l'aiu astier est en négociations
avec une société pharmaceutique pour les
droits de commercialisation du vaccin
le produit sera ensuite soumis à des
tests rigoureux avant sa mise en marché
des tests adéquats doivent être menées
pour évaluer la sécurité du vaccin
notamment sud du retour à la virulence
et du dosage minima la commercialisation
de vaccins efficaces changerait la donne
pour les pays producteurs de porcs
le vétérinaire eagle brockhoff l expert
conseil en matière de santé animale au
conseil canadien du porc
il a visité plusieurs porcherie qui se
trouvait au coeur des premiers foyers
d'éclosion du virus en chine une
technologie pourrait permettre un retour
à la normale chez les producteurs de
porcs de chine et d'asie du sud-est et
koné en réduisant les taux d'infection à
travers le monde
le risque de voir arriver le virus chez
nos producteurs en serait diminuée mais
il ya un hic le vaccin produit par les
américains est un vaccin vivant
or l'utilisation de ce type de vaccin
comporte de nombreux risques
les molécules atténuer présente dans le
vaccin pourrait elle retrouver leur
virulence et introduire la maladie chez
nous entre deux et six au canada
l'utilisation d'un tel vaccin pourrait
aussi mettre à risque
nos exportations de viande porcine un
marché annuel de 4 milliards de dollars
c'est qu'en utilisant un vaccin vivant
il devient difficile de distinguer dans
les produits du porc le virus actif du
vaccin lui-même points à 1 au monde
disent les maladies animales qui se
développe à l'étranger compte remettre
les exportations mais nos critères
élevés de biosécurité empêche les virus
d'entrer au pays vaut que gerets est du
même avis il est le directeur de vidéos
entre vague un centre de recherche à
l'université de la saskatchewan
spécialisée dans les maladies
infectieuses humaines et animales
ces laboratoires sont parmi les plus
sécuritaires au monde
derrière ses vitres se trouvent
plusieurs virus mortel la grippe aviaire
le strass cov 2 qui causent la coved 19
et depuis janvier 2020 la peste porcine
africaine
je pense que le canada n'utilisera pas
de vaccin vivant à cause du risque de
transmission du virus
nous tentons plutôt de créer un vaccin
basé sur un vecteur un adénovirus
utilise un adénovirus pin offensif pour
les parents comme véhicule pour
implanter des composants de la peste
porcine africaine dans leur système
immunitaire
aucun moment le virus vivants anti
n'était nos culé nos preuves d'euros
dans ce laboratoire le virologue serait
ch'tis coût et son équipe
créer des combinaisons d'adn ou virus
commun et de protéines provenant de la
peste porcine africaine
nous avons identifié à peu près trente
six protéines ayant un potentiel
d'antigènes vacciner les jeunes l'on a
des adénovirus qui seront administrées
aux animaux afin d'évaluer l'efficacité
des antigènes
le but susciter une réponse immunitaire
chez l'animal en lui administrant
seulement une partie du génome du virus
les essais cliniques sur des animaux
vivants devrait commencer à l'hiver 2020
nous allons immunisés ces animaux et dix
à douze jours plus tard nous les
exposeront au virus
puis nous surveillerons leur température
les décès certains animaux mangent moins
tombe malade
nous serons donc si certains de ces
antigènes créer une réponse immunitaire
efficace ou non
ces chercheurs ont aussi un autre
objectif créer un marqueur immunologique
dans leurs vaccins cela leur permettrait
de distinguer le vexin du virus vivants
c'est un outil important pour maintenir
le commerce mondial puisque nous
pourrons dire que tel ou tel port est
immunisée sans avoir été atteints du
virus et l'homologation de vaccins
animaux au canada relève de l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
la cia à perte et le commandant
d'incidents du centre national des
opérations d'urgence pour la peste
porcine africaine
dès que vaccin sera disponible peu
importe ses composantes
il sera évalué par la cia on veut
s'assurer que le vaccin agit comme il se
doit à savoir est-ce qu'il protège
adéquatement à l'animal vaccinés contre
la maladie
est-ce que les libère développent la
maladie même légèrement en dépit du
vaccin
on évalue aussi les impacts commerciaux
possibles du vaccin
je tiens à souligner que le type de
vaccin n'est pas une raison pour
favoriser ou écarter complètement un
produit la cia pour est homologué un
vaccin vivant s'il s'avérait être le
seul vaccin disponible pour stopper le
virus si celui ci devait un jour faire
son entrée sur le continent il s'est en
exemple la fièvre aphteuse
il existe un vaccin efficace
le problème c'est qu'il est difficile de
déterminer à partir d'échantillons
sanguins
les anticorps sont présents un réseau
d'accès dont le canada n'a pas donné son
approbation pour une vaccination de
routine mais conserve le vaccin en cas
d'urgence
si une épidémie se déclarer
une chose est certaine la course au
vaccin contre la peste porcine africaine
est lancé desprès
la question n'est pas de savoir si la
maladie arrivera ici mais plutôt dans
combien de temps et sera là c'est une
course contre la montre et même s'ils
sont un objectif commun ils savent bien
qu au vainqueur le butin nos partenaires
commerciaux savent que ce vaccin est une
mine d'or pour ce qu'ils produisent en
premier c'est une vraie course
pour james rohff et les familles de sa
communauté
la mise en marché d'un vaccin dans un
avenir proche leur permettrait de dormir
l'esprit tranquille
tous nos c'est rassurant de savoir que
des compagnies travaillent sur un vaccin
si la peste porcine africaine arrivé ici
nous aurions des outils pour la
condamner
[Musique]